[Music]
one of the important plot-setting
developments narrated early on in ursula
k le guin's sixth and last earth sea
novel the other wind is the relation
between two kings the king of the kargs
and the king of the archipelago the
other peoples of earthsea
and everything revolves around a
demand that is made by
the new high king of the cargs upon the
at that time reigning for roughly 15
years king of earth sea lebanon
and it has to do with a ring and with a
princess as yet unnamed we're not going
to find her name out until considerably
later
in the novel and so lebanon has been
king of earth see really since he came
back
from the land of death with with the ark
mage gad and ged did homage to him on
rogue soon afterwards he's going to be
crowned we saw that in the fourth earth
sea novel
and now he's been raining for quite a
while
so we find out that
um one of the things on his mind is the
emissaries of the high king of the kargs
they're about to take their leave having
accomplished their mission to have nora
to their own satisfaction if not at all
to that of lebanon's and he says he
looked forward to the visit of these
ambassadors of the culmination of years
of patient overture
invitation and negotiation for the first
10 years of his reign he had been able
to accomplish
nothing at all with the kargs why the
god king and awabath rejected his offers
of treaties and trade and sent his
envoys back unheard declaring that gods
do not parlay with vile mortals least of
all with accursed sorcerers and the the
kargs view the rest of the residents of
earth sea which they they don't actually
know how big the lands are that the
cargs are actually just a small portion
of it they view them as dark accursed
sorcerer folk that have betrayed you
know some some ancient pact and they
used to send their their people out to
raid this is how get actually and the
very first novel was able to display his
his magical abilities fighting against
the kargish warriors
and they're a rather insular people pun
intended there because everybody on
earth sea is living on one island or
another but the kargs are really a
people apart and the god king who was
part of essentially a new religious cult
a fairly new religious cult going back
to several generations
had established
you know his power as supreme and also
you know viewed the uh the other earth
sea people as not even worth dealing
with
then something happens
there's a
new thing but it's also kind of an
old thing
so
from melissa traders news first came of
the rise of the high king on her at her
the big poor easternmost island of the
car god lands a warlord thole
who claims dissent from thorig who is a
very important character in the
backstory going all the way back to
the tombs of ottawa right thorig is uh
leading a
revolt against you know some of the the
others who will eventually become the
god kings um
thorig and the god
had made himself high king of that land
of the the
you know the easternmost island
then he conquered ottnini then with a
fleet and an invading army he claimed
dominion over the rich central island
while his warriors were fighting their
way towards ahwabath the capital city
the people of the city rose up against
the tyranny of the god king slaughtered
the high priest drove the bureaucrats
out of the temple threw the gates wide
and welcomed king tholl to the throne of
thoreg with banners and dancing in the
streets the god king fled
to the tombs of ottawa there in the
desert one of his priest eunuchs cut the
god king's throat so thorig or thole
rather proclaimed himself high king of
the four car god lands as soon as
lebanon finds out about it he sends
ambassadors to greet his brother king
and assure him of the friendly
disposition of the archipelago
does that produce an immediate result no
that leads to five years of diplomacy
going back and forth and it's it's
understandable right so
first has to consolidate his power
but he himself is also a little
suspicious of the earth sea
archipelagons and then you know the high
king at hovnor
uh it meant nothing to him their king
talked about friendship flourishing the
ring of peace why because the ring
itself is kind of a bone of contention
right eric ethpa brought the the ring
which was not originally his it was a
gift from morad to alpharon he brings it
and it's broken by the high priest who
he fights with and uh eric
gives one piece to
thor egg
who is going to
as we you know now see
his lineage is restored here with the
new high king so you know the ring who
does it really belong to there's a good
claim on the part of the kargish people
that
the ring might have originally been you
know uh alpharon's but it's really
theirs and so why do why do the earth
see people have it well because it was
stolen from the kargish people right
um the priests of
about broke the pledge broke the ring
some 40 years ago sparrow hawk of rogue
and tenor of ottawan healed the ring
what of
the peace
that had been the gist of his messages
to king thought
and then suddenly an envoy comes ships
come sailing up
and
soul sends two things do two main things
there's a lot of people along the ships
the most important is his daughter
who at this point is unnamed and you
can't even see her because she is
covered with a veil that goes from the
brim of her hat
all the way down to her feet red with
gold lines in it right something like a
chimney as one of the women says and
also a message
what is the message the message is
let his daughter wear the ring
this is not just a fashion symbol though
this is incredibly
important it is fraught with
implications as we say so here's what he
actually says let the daughter of seoul
the high king who sits on the throne of
thoreg and whose ancestor was wuloa wear
the ring of peace upon her arm as queen
elferan of solea wore it and this will
be a sign
of everlasting peace between the western
and the eastern islands
so what he's offering him is essentially
a
normalizing of relations
take my daughter
give her the ring
which by the way means marrying her
and you'll be my son-in-law and our
lands
will have peace forevermore
doesn't that sound great what a
wonderful offering lebanon
not so cool on that offer right he's uh
avoided getting married all this time
now he's he is a king and in you know we
know this in the history of our own uh
you know earth
many many marriages were made not on the
basis of knowing the person or being in
love with them
but on the basis of creating important
alliances this was something that was
very often done for example in in the
middle ages but even in ancient times as
well
and so the question is what is lebanon
going to do
he takes a middle course
he doesn't accept
he doesn't reject
he doesn't deny
he says the great king though does this
the high king though does this great
honor
uh you are welcome here princess let the
princess be lodged in the river house
and let all be as she
desires and so this is doing some great
honor this is putting the princess who
now he has to figure out what am i going
to do with this woman and these demands
add a bit of a distance
right she's not lodged in the new palace
with him
and he can defer and delay
to a
certain extent
he says cheese in a rat trap a pig in a
poke a piece of goods the ring on her
arm and the collar round my neck this
gives you an idea about how he perceives
it lebanon is not happy as a matter of
fact he is
uncharacteristically angry as his uh you
know his server oak realizes and as
tenar is going to realize as well when
she comes to
visit
um he's angry because he feels that he's
being
tricked being used
and he says oak by my name i will
destroy thole in his kingdom before i
let him use me as a footstool to his
throne
he had not said he accepted the offer of
the princess as his bride all agreed she
had been offered to him as his bride the
language about el faron's ring barely
veiled the offer or the bargain or the
threat but he had not refused it either
his response
had been to say she was welcome that all
should be as he desired she desired and
she should live in the river house
surely that was significant
so we've got
some interesting things going on and
fortunately tennar is coming to give the
prince council or the king council
rather now
for
a separate issue that's coming up but
she says uh you know you can help me
with this as well
and he tells her for five years i've
built up trade and tried to keep on good
terms with foal because he's a warlord
and i don't want my kingdom pinched as
it was in the last king's reign maharion
between dragons in the west and warlords
in the east and because i rule in the
sign of peace and it went well enough
until this tilly sends this girl out of
the blue saying if you want peace give
her alpharon's ring your ring tenor
yours and geds and tenner says well she
is his daughter after all
and he says what's a daughter to a
barbarian king goods
a bargaining piece to buy advantage with
you know that you were born
there and so he's talking about the sort
of real politique you know of
ancient kingship
daughters who will become wives are
basically bargaining chips
and you know we don't know anything
about her at this way
at this point in time and he says she
can't even communicate tenar
and so tenor says you know there's
another way to look at this
i'm going to go and speak to her because
we speak the same language and what does
she find out when she goes and speaks to
the princess the princess doesn't even
know there's other languages and she has
no idea what's going on she just sees
people muttering gibberish at her all
day long and you know it's very
disconcerting
she thinks that all the people are
mocking her by chattering and yapping
like animals without human speech and
she's grown up you know in a very
isolated environment so she's afraid
and
lebanon then says well i can't marry her
i'll send her back and tenor says whoa
if you do that
you are dishonoring her
and
foal might kill her to keep the dishonor
from his house he'll certainly consider
that you intend to dishonor
him
and so you know they come to a
resolution
which is a resolution to delay a bit
more but one that's actually going to be
very important for the plot of this
novel
she's got to be able to speak his
language and until
this new princess from the kargish lands
can learn hardik
through tenor helping her
he doesn't have to make a decision at
all so he he he says that
i'll tell thole a heart of king can't
marry a woman who doesn't speak the
language of the realm i don't care if he
doesn't like it he needs the slap and it
buys me
time and so tenor says you'll ask her to
learn hardik and he says how can i ask
her anything if she takes it all for
gibberish what possible use is there in
my going to her i thought perhaps maybe
you'd speak to her you must see what an
imposition this is using this girl to
make thole appear my equal using the
ring as a trap i can't even seem to
condone it but notice what he says next
i'm willing to temporize to delay
in order to keep the peace nothing more
even that much deceit is vile
tell the girl what you think best i will
have nothing to do with her and he
leaves a carefully worded message for
king though expressing his appreciation
of the honor of the princess's the
presence and the pleasure he and his
court would have in introducing her to
the manners customs and language of his
kingdom he said nothing at all about the
ring about marrying her or about not
marrying her and so this is you know
quite important and the ambassador says
the high king will be
pleased so the high king is getting more
or less what he wants you know maybe
he'll marry her if he doesn't then they
get to have a nice war
lebanon is not happy at all about this
turn of affairs but at least he's put
off the problem for the time being whose
interests have not been consulted in
this at all
the princess who
at this point we have no idea even what
she looks like
or you know what her name is
and we haven't had her consulted at all
in this matter
you